salut comment ça va alors aujourd'hui on
va parler de quoi on va paraître samsung
savoir quel smartphone samsung ht en
2022 l'heure c'est une question
intéressante parce que samsung est quand
même relativement large mais qui est
très très bien scindé vous avez
différents produits différentes familles
de produits chez samsung aujourd'hui on
va regarder ça on va essayer de
comprendre quel smartphone samsung ht en
2022 sera bien évidemment dépendre de
votre budget vous coacher et on y va
[Musique]
il ya plusieurs points hyper importants
à venir regarder lorsqu'on veut acheter
un smartphone pourquoi et bien parce que
l'on veut acheter un smartphone pour ces
usages en a tous des usages un petit peu
différent le regard des usages qu'on va
venir retrouver et bien déjà tout le
côté divertissement à venir regarder des
films des séries à venir regarder son
écran ça c'est le premier point donc il
nous faut souvent un grand écran bel
écran avoir une belle qualité il ya
aussi toute une partie qui se développe
énormément et de plus en plus c'est le
gaming et les marques investissent
énormément sur le gaming et qu'il ya un
usage extrêmement important c'est toute
la partie photo vidéo parce qu'on veut
un excellent smartphone pour pouvoir
faire des photos avoir des souvenirs ou
alors pourquoi pas faire des vidéos
qu'on va venir poster sur les réseaux
sociaux et notamment sur tik tok entre
autres sur instagram sur youtube enfin
bref dans beaucoup d'endroits mais
également on veut quoi et bien des fois
on veut faire un peu de productivité on
veut prendre des notes on veut
travailler c'est un outil travail
relever des mails écrirait compagnie p
puis à notre usage qui est extrêmement
important et surtout ce qu'on veut ou
pas ces avoirs de la 5g grâce à dieu ça
peut être relativement pratique si par
exemple vous voulez jouer la veillée au
plat vous voulez pas trop de latence si
vous voulez un débit de dingue ça peut
valoir le coup et au milieu de tout ça
et bien il ya la question du budget
parce que fatalement des smartphones ça
coûte cher donc savoir quel smartphone
rentrer dans votre budget on va donc
regarder tous ces points là mais juste
avant il ya un pas qui est super
important on y regarder c'est comprendre
un petit peu les gammes comment
s'articulent les gammes chez samsung
alors regarder se prend mon plus beau
stabilo vous avez allez vous avez on va
dire cap diamant réalité trois gammes
chez samsung vous avez la première gamme
qu'on va appeler la gamme galaxy tous
appellent galaxy au niveau des
smartphones c'est la gamme galaxy z ça
ce sont les smartphones qui se plie dans
la gamme galaxy z vous avez deux grandes
familles de produits vous allez avoir le
set fold et vous allez avoir le z flip
le z folle l'idée de cette fraude vous
avez un smartphone vous l'ouvrez pour
agrandir la surface utile l'idée d'une
flic vous le prenez vous le rétrécissent
et vous le pays en deux pour réduire la
surface utile c'est vraiment cette
grande famille là alors on va passer
très rapidement parce que si vous voulez
acheter un de ces deux produits vous
savez pourquoi vous y allez pour
innovation dont bon on va aller très
très très rapidement vous avez également
la gamme qu'on va appeler la gamme
galaxy away une fois de plus ce galaxy s
sas et la gamme photos vidéos et
aujourd'hui productivité parce qu'avant
vous aviez la gamme galaxy note c'était
le smartphone pour trouver au mois de
juillet août avec un stylet avec un spd
sauf qu'aujourd'hui c'est de garde elle
n'existe plus elle n'est pas sorti
l'année dernière et on retrouve un style
est directement intégré dans le samsung
galaxy s 22 ultra donc la gamme galaxy s
ça va être la photo ça va être aussi la
vidéo s'arrête la gamme de la
performance également de la productivité
et qui peut le plus peut le moins on
pourrait faire tout le reste avec bien
évidemment et puis ensuite vous avez
notre grande famille qui est aussi super
intéressante c'est la gamme galaxy a
alors la gamme galaxy âge mais la m avec
à peu près en même temps que la gamme
galaxy m ouh là vous allez être je
dirais dans le milieu entrée de gamme
avec des produits un peu moins cher mais
qui vont être extrêmement intéressant et
qui vous permettront également de faire
de la photo qui auront suffisamment de
performance mais toute la question de
productivité tout ça on oublie alors on
y va pour tout vous dire je vous hais
j'ai bien travaillé sur ce petit papier
là sauf que ça s'est un peu trop
compliqué pour vous donc ce fait un peu
des deux mémoires pour venir re situer
un petit peu tout ça alors moi je veux
qu'on re situer un petit peu paris gamme
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans la
gamme galaxy s on va commencer par celle
là la gamme galaxy sl est vachement
intéressante parce qu'on l'a vu sortir
il n'ya pas longtemps parce qu'on a vu
arriver en 2022 et l'acsi s22 es22 plus
s22 ultra sons des smartphones qui se
ressemblent beaucoup entre le f-22 et
es22 plus la différence que vous allez
voir c'est la taille de la batterie 7 la
taille de l'écran mais sinon il raconte
à peu près la même histoire donc si vous
voulez un excellent smartphone pour la
photo pour la vidéo vous voulez de la
performance vous voulez en gros ce qui
est mieux aujourd'hui chez samsung dans
le haut de gamme galaxy s 22 es22 plus
ça ce sont vraiment les deux smartphones
que je vais venir vous recommander si
vous voulez du très haut de gamme et si
vous avez le budget parce qu'ici on se
parle quand même de 859 euros alors
attention les prix descendent assez vite
émile 59 euros une fois de plus si elle
s'est produit qui vous intéresse je vous
mets tous les liens en bas dans la
description là vous avez un processeur
c'est l'exil aux 2200 qui fonctionne
bien alors on a une version qui existe
mais pas ici c'est dans les us canada
une partie de l'asie avec un sabre un
goal de 8 de première génération mais
c'est pas chez nous donc ici on va se
contenter de l'exil aux 2200 qui du très
bon mais qui est moins bon que ne sera
bonne nuit de première génération peut
venir filmer aux médications soigne pas
trop d'intérêt ces smartphones là ils
vont être vraiment intéressant pour une
fois de plus le gaming la photo la vidéo
vous avez un superbe écran dynamique
amoled 2 x donc si vous voulez faire des
photos pour partager sur les réseaux
sociaux si vous voulez faire créer du
contenu filmé dit actuellement et elle
est même filmé en condition de nuit il
fonctionne très bien ils sont
performants là-dessus aucun problème
alors un smartphone qui est encore un
petit peu à part et je vous le note ici
c'est le es22 ultra alors le f-22 ultra
il est bien mais vous avez un stylet
alors je dis paillard méjean ça fait
c'est un peu moins bien non c'est très
très bien vous avez un style et dont on
n'est plus dans l'idée de la
productivité mais c'est un très gros
smartphone aussi donc gros encombrements
la cdu 6 8 pouces il est comme les
autres à hydra toutes les bonnes cas il
aura toutes les caractéristiques des
autres sauf qu'ici on n'en fera plus est
pareil en termes de photos une vidéo
d'une heure je vous ai fait une vidéo
pour vous en parler il marchera
parfaitement bien mais le prix tout de
suite il est à combien
1259 euros voilà c'est une jolie bête
alors après dans cette gamme la gamme
galaxy est si vous aimez la gamme galaxy
s est aussi un produit qui est super
intéressante et été présenté en début
d'année c'est le s 21 et feu alors le s
21 il faut c'est un bon compromis à 759
euros 759 euros au plat je vais y
arriver vous avez un snapdragon 888 très
performant il va être très bon photos
très bon vidéo il va aussi être bon pour
tout ce qui va être gaming series film
certes super compromis c'est comme un
samsung galaxy s 22 light avec un peu
moins de choses mais il reste très très
bon trio gagnent donc si vous n'avez pas
eu 159 euros ou que vous voulez pas
mettre ce budget là alors là vous le
trouvez à 759 euros je suis sûr que le
prix va diminuer dans quelques temps et
bien allez jeter un oeil parce que ça
c'est aussi super intéressant bon il a
on va commencer à changer un peu de
famille vous allez voir c'est super
intéressant parce que on va arriver dans
la gamme galaxy et galaxy m le milieu de
gamme c'est là où s'ajoutent celles là
où on va retrouver le plein de produits
intéressants elle regarde ici vous allez
avoir le à 72 vous allez avoir le à 53
vous allez avoir le à 42 vous allez
avoir le à 33 vous allez avoir le a100
fait quelques-uns 21s vous allez avoir
le à 12 vous allez avoir le à 12 02 s
voilà principalement alors ce qu'il faut
venir le savoir ici c'est que là tout
moment je tourne cette vidéo et vient
tous les produits de 2022 ne sont pas
sortis à savoir que la regarder vous
voyez le à 72 on va voir un à 73 qui va
arriver donc il va être mis à jour on a
à 42 on aura lieu à 43 qui va sortir
également le à 21 s on aura peut-être en
a 22 ans 23 et j'en sais rien 01/12 on
aura un à treize et un an 0,2 à 104 1 à
0 3 donc les choses vont évoluer ce qui
est sûr et soulevait déjà présenté on a
le à 53 élus à 33 le smartphone qui
cartonne qui se vendra le mieux qui le
meilleur rapport qualité prix
aujourd'hui c'est celui là c'est le à 53
donc si vous voulez je dirais le
meilleur rapport qualité prix coûte
combien 53 il est à 459 euros alors 459
euros ça fait un peu d'argent on s'en
doutera mais à 459 euros vous avez de la
5g vous avez un écran super amoled avec
une diagonale de 6 25 pouces avec un
taux de rafraîchissement non adaptatif 1
220 r c'est à dire que c'est à vous de
venir switcher entre 2 60 et 120 hertz
mais si vous voulez jouer 200 vaillard
vous pouvez y aller sans aucun problème
sur l'ensemble de la gamme là vous avez
des batteries de 5000 millions père earl
va y avoir une petite différence est que
certains rôles la recharge rapide 25
quoique tron la recharge 15 watts bon
pour apprendre un peu plus son mal en
patience mais dans tous les cas c'est du
5 millions perreur jusqu'au 1 21 est si
vous faites de la vidéo pourrait bien
filmé jusqu'à 4-4 en images par seconde
après c'est du 1080p à 30 images par
seconde bon très honnêtement ces
smartphones là sont pas des smartphones
qui sont faits pour faire de la vidéo si
vous voulez faire de la vidéo de bonne
qualité que vous allez sur les galaxy s
si vous cherchez des smartphones etc de
la 5g les à 53 à 42 et à 33 sont tous
les 3 5g les autres ne sont pas du tout
5 g mais quand arrivera le à 72 je suis
sûr que le à 72 sera 5 j'ai peut-être
pas les autres en dessous mais celui-là
je sois qu'ils racontent ils arrivent à
istres à samedi autre élément qui est
hyper important jusqu'au à 21 est ce là
vous avez tous des écrans super amoled
ça c'est super intéressant parce que ce
n'est pas ce que ça me saoule maîtrise
vraiment bien ces écrans et en dessous
là vous avez du lcd cd et cd dalle tft
tous les écrans dossier entre 6,7 6 5 6
à 8 4 pouces donc les diagonales sont à
peu près les mêmes au niveau de la photo
là sur les deux vous avez un capteur
principal en grand angle là ici de 64
mégapixels ensuite jusqu'au à 12 vous
arrivez ici là ça c'est tout du 48 spla
grand-angle ici de 48 mégapixels bon et
la sas des gradins la cdu 13 mégapixels
mais bon voilà on en a aussi pour son
argent là c'est la même chose à vous
avez un ultra grand angle de 12
mégapixels pour sauf que là ici vous
êtes jusque là à 8 mégapixels et là vous
arrivez sur le à 12 à 5 mégapixels sur
l' ultra grand angle donc là on dit bien
placé le grand angle et là c'est l'ultra
grand enquête vous allez retrouver du
mode portrait ou d'un maquereau de 2 ou
5 mégapixels ça va pas changer grand
chose parce que ça sera pas dingue dans
tous les cas il ya un autre truc à
savoir qui est extrêmement important
c'est qu'à partir du à 12 la garder à 12
là vous avez 64 giga de stockage et là
vous avez carrément 32 gigas de stockage
donc c'est avec cette de smartphones le
à 12 et le à 0,2 s alors effectivement
ils vont être beaucoup moins cher mais
en termes de capacité de stockage vous
allez rapidement être limité dans ce que
vous allez venir installer ici après
c'est pas les smartphones qui vont être
extrêmement performant on va pas venir
installer des jeunes dingue va pas
mettre des trucs de dingue dedans c'est
toujours une question de budget parce
que regarder on va revenir sur la notion
du budget le à 72 a le regard des
moments où j'ai trouvé les infos
j'arrive à le trouver à 399 euros mais
bon c'est un prix discount il a baissé
celui là là je vous ai dit à 459 euros
le à 42 j'ai trouvé à 380 euros le à 33
il coûta sa sortie 379 euros le à 21 ans
on est à 2 133 euros le à 12 225 euros
et lui la 185 euros alors les prix
baissent beaucoup et baisse au bout de
deux trois mois chez samsung ce qui nous
permet de voir qui est une vraie
différence et ça paraît pas tous très
cohérent mais il est évident que lorsque
le à 73 5 g va arriver il va être plus
cher que 459 euros par rapport aux 33
donc on va se rapprocher ainsi des 500
euros 500 et quelques ronds après on
s'en doutera plus on va monter au niveau
du numéro et plus on aura un smartphone
performance apparaît assez logique donc
le truc il faut vraiment venir retenir
ici en fait c'est que le smartphone qui
fonctionnera mieux qui sera le meilleur
rapport qualité prix pour moi ça va être
celui-là siècle à 53 vous avez tout ce
qui convient vous avez tout ce qu'il
faut au niveau de la photo vous aurez le
même capteur que le à 72 ou 73 qui
potentiellement devrait arriver c'est
vrai pourquoi toujours la même chose
vous avez un super rapport qualité prix
que vous avez de la 5g vous avez un
superbe écran super amoled bref un très
très jolie smartphones mais je comprends
que 459 euros ça reste un gros budget je
dirais que jusqu'au à 33 on a deux
choses qui sont assez assez cool assez
cohérente après on va quand même
vachement baissé en termes de spec on
aura des choses qui sont beaucoup moins
intéressante et l'expérience va se
dégrader non je dirais qu'à partir du à
21 ans j'irai voir un petit peu quand
même ailleurs à la concurrence qui se
passe et est-ce que j'ai des choses qui
sont intéressantes peut-être du côté de
chez chuo me mettre du côté de chez
opodo faut aller comparer mais entre le
à 72 il ya 73 qui devrait arriver
bientôt le à 53 le à 42 problement leva
43 et le à 33 c'est pour moi le coeur de
gamme et c'est la gamme qui est la plus
intéressante ici avec un gros focus sur
la 53 une fois de plus t il à 459 euros
mais tu arrives à bien abc alors après
il ya un truc que je voulais vous
montrer sa vie de plus de place dans les
feuilles qui est intéressant c'est good
to se bat c'est la gamme on va appeler
la galaxie m d'ailleurs qui s'appelle la
galaxie m alors la galaxie mc encore un
peu différent aujourd'hui tout de suite
au moment qu'ils ont fait cette vidéo
j'ai deux références à vous présenter je
vais avoir le n 32 mais je doute pas le
devoir m 33 km sortir et j'ai un m12 qui
sont tous les deux à 299 euros et 179
euros sur le m 32 à un peu moins de 300
euros savoir un écran super amoled avec
une diagonale de 6 5 4 pouces j'ai des
batteries 25 millions perreur également
ici ça bouge pas sur l'aim 30 de juin
elio 80 sur le m 12 janek zinos aux 850
là je vais avoir un capteur de 64
mégapixels âge avoir un capteur
principal de 48 mégapixels bon le seul
truc un peu faiblard sur le m 12 c'est
que j'ai un stockage de 64 gigas c'est
un peu moyen parce que une fois de plus
dès que je commence à admettre des
choses dedans à ça peut vraiment manqué
je peux rapidement être embêté là je
fais en 128 samba déjà tout de suite
plus alors ici j'ai pas de 5 g je suis
en 4g uniquement et là je vais voir un
écran avec une résolution full hd + qui
est quand même plutôt pas mal sur le m
32 tandis que là je suis en hd + n'ont
pas moyens tout qui vachement
intéressant ici c'est ce m 32 à 299
euros on peut le 3e joueur encore un peu
moins cher deux fois de plus vous tous
les liens embarque dans la description
que c'est un super rapport qualité prix
et ça ça conviendra parfaitement bien
donc s'il faut vraiment venir tenir ici
si vous voulez de l'innovation pure et
dure si vous voulez un truc un peu
différent et que vous avez beaucoup
d'argent et budget z fold it slip ça ça
marche bon c'est tout de suite beaucoup
plus cher quoique explique encore il ya
eu des super promo avec des offres de
reprise et une époque on ne trouvait pas
trop cher que ça c'était quand même
vachement intéressant c'est pour moi un
des smartphones les plus canons j'ai vu
chez sam sont ensuite la gamme galaxy s
photos vidéos performances avec je
dirais un gros focus sur le s 22 s 22
points de plus qui sera un poil plus
grand avec une batterie un peu plus
grande le s20 d'ultra il est très
particulier si vous voulez un aspect why
note si vous voulez un très gros
smartphone why not et puis coûte très
cher et puis sinon je dirais que dans la
gamme galaxy a le à 53 qui va être hyper
canon j'attends de voir le à 73 qui ne
saurait tarder je pense également 5 j'ai
eu à 53 plus plus plus à voir si vous
n'avez pas le budget on peut les sur 1
42 pour le mans 43 bientôt et le à 33
que je trouve assez sympa également mais
avec un gros focus une fois de plus
jeudi sur le à 53 les autres à 21 aces à
12 et à
02 sv - y aller je trouve moins
intéressants qu'ils sont moins cool par
contre on peut quand même dire jeter un
petit coup d'oeil sur le m 32
probablement le m 33 qui arrivera
bientôt que je trouve aussi super
intéressant donc voilà après ça dépend
effectivement de vous de votre budget ça
dépend de vos usages film series à tous
les smartphones sont quand même
relativement cool même le même 32 pour
me regarder que des films et des séries
si vous voulez faire de la photo je
dirais que ben écoutez on va commencer à
aller sur le à 53 c'est quand même pas
mal en dessous c'est un peu un peu moins
volontaire vers des photos pour gagner
il nous faut de la performance pareille
vers le à 53 vous aurez quelque chose
qu'il conviendra et le reste aidez vous
allez monter dans la gamme à vous aurait
pas de problème ça marchera vachement
bien et la question de l'autonomie vous
avez dû 5000 milliards père heures
partout le logiciel c'est le même c'est
one way qui fonctionne très bien donc
pas de souci là dessus et après ça peut
varier d'un processeur à l'autre mais
bon ça n'a pas vraiment changé la face
de l'histoire alors voilà je ne sais pas
si ça vous aura aidé parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'informations il ya beaucoup
de smartphones si on doit retenir une
chose c'est à 53 que je trouve très cool
leather ça va dépendre un peu du budget
commun soit votre budget doit
s'articuler autour de saez 22s 20 de
plus le s 21 et feu qui reste toujours
un super compromis super rapport qualité
prix il devrait arriver un je pense
d'ici la fin de l'année un f-22 et feu
il sera probablement aussi intéressant
on en reparlera plus tard on venait vous
abonner ce n'est pas déjà le cas et et
cliquez sur la petite cloche un acte iv
moi cette cloche pour notifier qu'une
prochaine vidéo arrivera nous on
retrouve très bientôt pour continuer à
parler tech de samsung et j'espère que
ça vous aurait intéressé si vous avez
des questions interrogations suggestion
c'est juste en bas dans les commentaires
de nous rendre à ce rendez vous très
bientôt 10 ou 15
[Musique]